one of the things that separates
confident from diffident people is their
approach to history broadly speaking the
unconfident believe that history is over
the confident trust that it's still in
the process of being made one day
possibly by themselves the way we enter
the world carries with it an inherent
bias towards an impression that change
has finished and history has been
settled everything around us conspires
to give off a sense that the status quo
is entrenched we're surrounded by big
people who follow traditions that have
been in place for decades perhaps
centuries the house we live in appears
as immutable as an ancient temple the
school we go to looks as though it had
been performing the same rituals since
the earth began we're constantly told
why things are the way they are and
encouraged to accept that reality is not
made according to our wishes we come to
trust that human beings have fully
mapped the range of the possible if
something hasn't happened it's either
because it can't happen or it shouldn't
the result can be a deep weariness
around imagining changing the world
there's no point starting a new business
the market must be full already
pioneering a new approach to the arts
everything is already set in a fixed
pattern or giving loyalty to a new idea
it either exists or is mad when we study
history in a certain way however the
picture changes sharply once time is
speeded up and we climb up a mountain of
minutes and survey centuries change
appears constant new continents are
discovered alternative ways of governing
nations of pioneered ideas of how to
dress and whom to worship a transformed
once people wore strange clothes and
till the land with clumsy instruments a
long time ago they chopped a king's head
off way back people got around in
fragile ships ate the eyeballs of sheep
used chamber pots and didn't know how to
fix teeth we come away from all this
knowing at least in theory that things
do change but in practice almost without
noticing we tend to distance ourselves
and our own societies from a day-to-day
belief that we belong to the same on
turbulent narrative and are at present
its central actors history we feel is
what used to happen it can't really be
what's happening around us in the here
and now things have in our vicinity at
least settle down to make us braver
about the idea of changing things today
we might turn to some striking lines in
TS Eliot's cycle of poems the Four
Quartets so while the light fails on a
winter's afternoon in a secluded chapel
history is now and England winter
afternoons around 4:00 p.m. have a habit
of feeling particularly resolved and
established especially in quiet English
country chapels many of which date back
to the Middle Ages the air in such
chapels is still and musty the heavy
stone floors have been slowly worn away
by the feet of the faithful these are
not places and times to think about
changing the world
everything hints that we would be wiser
to accept the way things are walk back
home across the fields light a fire and
settle down for a quiet evening
hence the surprise of Eliot's third line
his resonant history is now and England
in other words everything that we
associate with history the impetuous
daring of great people the dramatic
alterations in values the revolutionary
questioning of long-held beliefs the
upturning of the old order all this is
still going on even at this very moment
in outwardly peaceful apparently
unchanging places like the countryside
near Shamli Green in Surrey where Eliot
wrote his poem we don't see it only
because we are standing far too close
the world has been made and remade at
every instant and therefore any one of
us has a theoretical chance of being an
agent in history on a big or small scale
it's open to our own times to build a
new city every bit as beautiful as
Venice to change ideas as radically as
the Renaissance to start an intellectual
movement as resounding as Buddhism the
present has all the contingency of the
past and is every bit as malleable it
shouldn't intimidate us how we love
travel approach the arts govern educate
ourselves front businesses
age and dye are all up for further
development current views may appear
firm but only because we exaggerate
their fixity the majority of what exists
is arbitrary
neither inevitable nor right simply the
result of muddled and happenstance we
should be confident even at sunset on
winter afternoons of our power to join
the stream of history and however
modestly
change its course
you